if you weren't making these films what
would you be doing
you know I it's a good question I I
think about that a lot I feel like I I
always had a dream that I would be like
in behind the scenes in politics like
that's kind of what that political film
spin is about is about the guy behind
the guy you know kind of working the
world yeah yeah trying to make trying to
make good things happen from afar and I
don't know I like that idea I mean I I
liked it a lot better about three months
ago but you know it's I think there's a
need for it and people that are willing
to fight you know to get in the game and
be brave and you know stand for
something I I like all that stuff and
like I try to do that on my sets I try
to do that with my films you know but
like we need it just in the world we
just need people that are willing to
take a stand well in a lot of sense that
is a director the person that you're
talking about or no it's not a spin
doctor but it's it's somebody that's you
know grooming and giving advice and
right the politician it's a little more
paternal I guess then you know most spin
doctors or whatever but it's the same
thing it's like I'm taking care of my
guy like my actors they're my guys you
know it's like I'm not gonna let them
get hurt I'm not gonna let them look bad
like we're trying to do something bigger
and what I want is you know the the
raising tide raises all boats that's
what we want we want everybody going up
with us you don't I mean that's kind of
off the topic but that's what I feel
like the job of the director is is like
you're protecting the movie and you're
protecting your team and if anything
goes wrong in that it's a directress
nip it in the bud you know or fix it
well so that whoever that spin-doctor
more paternal spin-doctor role is my
sense is if you really wanted to do it
you would have done it by now because
you strike me as a type that sets out to
do whatever you plan yeah why I love
what I do I really love what I do you
know I mean like in like getting to tell
stories and then having a team that you
believe in that believes in you
I mean it's it's worth its weight in
gold it really is I
it means a lot to me you know I like I
could do this if I could make a movie a
year I'd be a happy guy you know it's
like doing a movie every four years is
trying but you know a lot of people
haven't done for movies you know I have
and I I I love doing it I'll do it as
long as people at me
well you mentioned earlier that you're
about to turn 40 or I'm bout to turn 41
okay well you're a very young hey thanks
but you know and you and you recall how
out like wow I did something for 20
years I'm sure over that course of time
you've considered doing other things but
because you love it and you're willing
to stick it out whether it's a challenge
or whether it's great you've realized
that this is what I'm probably supposed
to be doing I kind of you know I have
this moment where I was thinking about
like where I am where do I want to be
you know I guess I'd stuff that you do
when you turn 40 you know and I was like
you know I've kind of gone too far to
throw it away
you know like I I I'm not really
interested in changing what I do but
like now I have you know like I said I
have four features they have eight
produced screenplays like people will
follow me and make a movie because I've
done it before and you know one way to
do be like well I'm kind of at the top
of this whole indie film game so I'm
gonna set off and teach history now it's
just I feel like I'm pretty locked into
this and you know I like it and I keep
working and you know doing new things
I'm doing a you know a play this summer
that will be some musical so that's new
for me but like really now it's in
Louisiana you know at this equity house
down there but like I have not done a
musical since I was you know nine years
old so I love doing new things and like
challenging myself and like trying to
keep the art popping and do things that
scare me you know yeah I think that's
really important I think so - yeah
and and with that comes some low times
and then some really high times because
those lows are
so bad yeah and then when stuff works
you go it was worth it
yeah I mean that's the thing it's like
and you know I friends who don't
understand my life at all you know
because the peaks are so high and the
valleys are very low but like the peaks
are great man like I tell you what like
standing you know being in Park City
standing next to Mark Harmon you know at
a film festival or like being in the
middle of Texas making a movie with Sam
Shepard you know or like wearing a
tuxedo a red carpet event in a movie
palace that was built in 1925 for cut to
the chase and Shreveport Louisiana I
mean that stuff is tried my bucket list
is pretty good you know what I mean you
know it's got its downsides too but like
I I really like the ride and with that
if some were to take that snapshot of
that tuxedo moment on the red carpet
they probably would think wow this guy's
this is cool like you know they don't
see all the hard work that got right at
that point and the crowdfunding how long
was the campaign was three months
normally something like that every
months okay so all that that took to get
that money plus you said it was you had
some extra money oh yeah
then it was raising money from that
point from the time that we got the
Kickstarter money all the way until I
raised more money for distribution three
weeks ago right so if you were to take
that snapshot so it's a movie of
layovers life yeah and then you
backtrack though and there was a lot of
at the computer alone without the wine
with the coffee right you know well you
know I mean that what's funny is is like
that's kind of our reality now isn't it
you know with like the Facebook and the
Instagram and the Twitter is like I show
people what I want them to see you know
and not exactly what like it's just I'm
marketing me like I market my films and
I think it's very important and I think
that a lot of filmmakers don't do it to
their detriment because we mentioned
earlier the brand my brand you know I
feel like it has a lot to do with why
people will buy the movie you know will
show up for the Q&A well you know and
you gotta keep that marketing going as
well I a friend of mine runs a
you know and we do very much the same
thing you know he's a theater guy you
know I'm mostly in film but like we're
doing the same thing all the time we're
you know telling people what our company
is what it stands for what kind of work
we're doing and why you should want to
be a part of it you know I mean and like
I know filmmakers are just like I don't
know how you raise money huh like well
if you try and you learn then you have
the power otherwise you have to find
somebody with power and ask them you
know for permission if you take it
yourself you know I don't have to ask
permission for anyone you know and it's
it's a great place to be as far as art
goes why do you think a lot of
filmmakers don't want to do it just
because it's time-consuming it's scary
yes I think I think absolutely I mean
it's it's kind of gross
you know it's like there's lots of stuff
that that goes into you know dealing
with the financing that is not Fonzie
you know like there's yeah I mean you
know Fonzie shows about you know I did
this work with an actor once and I had
just done a Kickstarter kind of thing
and I was you know and he's just like
man I just couldn't do it I couldn't you
know put myself out there and ask for
money and I'm like well the good thing
is if I make a movie nobody remembers
that I bug them on Facebook you know
they just remember hey I gave five bucks
of this guy there's there's my movie you
know but people are really reluctant to
go out on a limb they everybody wants to
be the sure thing you know and I just it
really is hard when you when you're
seeking money everybody says no until
they don't you know and that's really
what it is but like that freedom that
being able to be the person who like I
put this financing together you know
this is my baby
so I don't have to listen to a studio he
says actually Blaine we're going with
somebody who's with CAA and is a little
hotter than you right now for this
directing gig thanks a lot for the
script and they can do that they can
just you know push me right out the door
but
nobody pushes Baby in the corner you
know what I mean
but anyways I like it I like it and I
just hope that financier keep believing
in me just real quickly what is the
Fonzie analogy I love this yeah well I
mean you know I we were talking earlier
about LA versus New York and I feel like
la is a very Fonzie culture they want
you know somebody to come in and just I
didn't practice at all I haven't had
time to look at this but I'm just really
cool I'm actually I might be cooler than
you are you know and New York they
really want the kind of nerdy you know
I've been preparing for this meeting for
six months you know they want to know
that you've got it together and then you
take it seriously I just think it's a
funny combo and I have I mean I you know
I've been lucky enough to work with some
really great actors who you know can do
both you know or make it look easy
breezy just pop in like Patrick J Addams
is a great example
he's on suits now and I've done two
movies with Patrick and he's totally
Fonzie it out and then in his hotel room
the night before he works he is Marlon
Brando in that stuff practicing you know
getting ready but then everything's just
as easy breezy and you know Naturals
could possibly be you know I love that
analogy yeah great any Millennials out
there watch happy being Manny's Fonzie I
don't get it
grew up on that side okay yeah
you